okay well welcome back we're gonna have
a our session now and once again we'll
use our studio
which is a very convenient uh a platform
for running R and for demonstrating r
so we'll go to our our screen now and
and we'll do a our studio session on
linear discriminant analysis first of
all and Then followed by nearest
neighbor classification
so here we are in our our studio
um
uh session window and the first thing we
do is we require islr that's our our
package with some of our data sets
so I hit the control button and return
and it loads the package and then we
require the mass package
um
which is venables and Ripley's package
of of useful functions and including the
function for doing linear discriminant
analysis
you'll see in the right hand panel I've
got a help file for linear discriminant
analysis so as always in R if you if you
don't know or you're not too familiar
with a new procedure you do help and
make sure you understand the syntax and
and all the options and so on
so
the first thing we do we're going to use
the stock market data here and the the
response is going to be the direction
that the market took on a particular day
and we're going to use the the Returns
on the previous two days to try and
predict the direction on on this
particular day
okay and so there we use a command
lda.fit
and it takes a formula so the response
is Direction
they're the two predictors it's telling
you the data comes from
is Market stock market
and we're going to use the subset which
is years less than 2005 and because
later on we're going to make predictions
for year 2005. so you can put that
directly in the formula subset equals
year less than 2005 and this variable
year of course is referenced in s market
as well as these variables over here
okay so off we go and we fitted
and
it fits it so very quickly and we print
it by just type in its name and there's
a little summary printed below you
and you see gives typically you get the
formula that was used to create it and
then it gives a summary of the linear
discriminant analysis so the prime
probabilities are just the proportions
of ups and downs in the data set it's
roughly 50 percent
which says something about the market
right
it's kind of a random walk half the time
it goes up half the time it goes down
it summarizes the group means in the for
the two groups for the downs and the UPS
looks like the maybe a slight difference
in these two groups the means seem to be
separated a little bit and then it gives
the LDA coefficients so if you remember
the LDA function fits a linear function
for separating the two groups and and so
it's got two coefficients okay well you
there's some methods that work for LDA
for example you can plot a LDA fit which
we'll do here and it gives a very
convenient plot
it it plots the linear discriminant
function
separately the values of the linear
discriminant function separately for the
the upgroup and the Down group
and when we look at this it looks to the
eye like there's really not much
difference those two histograms look
pretty much on top of each other
which of course is not a big surprise
because if we could very easily like
this predict the movement of the stock
market we'd be making lots of money and
we wouldn't be sitting there giving our
demonstrations
so now we're going to see how well our
rule predicts on the Year 2005 Okay so
and I'm doing this in a slightly
different way as to what was described
in the in the book
um
we first of all make a subset of of the
data frame s market and we'll call it s
market Dot 2005.
and we use the command in our useful
command called subset
and so the first argument is the data
frame that you're going to subset which
is s market and then
following that are some logical
Expressions that can use variables in
that data frame to define the subset and
so here it is year equals equals 2005.
okay and that will create
a data frame with just the Year 2005
observations
okay and so now we can
use that as the the test data or the
place where we want to make our
predictions so we call
um LDA dot we're called the predict
method for for an LDA fit and we give it
our fit and we give it this new data
frame s market.2005.
and it'll produce some predictions for
us and let's just print the first five
of these
and oops it didn't like that so it's not
I was assuming it was in a matrix format
and it's not
um so what format is it so we don't
throw up our hands and run away when we
get an error we just investigate so
let's look at the class of LDA dot print
well it's a list
now I happen to know what kind of list
it is and when you have a list of
variables and each of the variables have
the same number of observations
the convenient way of looking at such a
list is through data frame
and so we can do data frame of LDA pred
and then look at the first five rows
and this is what we get
and
you'll see what it gives is it gives a a
row name it gives the classification the
first five will all up
um two of the comp one of the components
of the list was a matrix of posterior
probabilities which had actually a two
column Matrix but data frame smart
enough to to understand that that can
also get you know that that these can
fit into the data frame and so it makes
two columns one for up and one foot down
the posterior probabilities and then
there's the actual values of the LDA
score
okay
and so now we can now we realize that
the the output of pred has these
different components the thing we're
really interested in here is the
classification so that's class so we're
going to do a table
of LDA pred dollar class that's a true
class label for the 2005 versus the
prediction
um
sorry that is the prediction
um versus the True Value right so this
is the predicted class and this is the
true value over here in the data frame
we'll do a table of that
right and that's we get the little
confusion Matrix which tells us which
Downs were classified as down which
Downs were classified as up and so on
okay and it's an off-diagonal elements
of those that are the mistakes
and and the diagonal Elements which are
the correct classifications and so one
simple command tells us how
correct classification rate which is we
got a conditional year which is the
predicted class is equal to the true
class
so that'll be true if it's if they're
equal and it'll be false if they're not
and since truths are and and forces can
be coerced to be zeros and ones we can
just take the mean of that and it'll
give us our
correct classification rate which in
this case is about 0.56
so it's not huge but again in in this
kind of industry any little Edge like
that that actually helps
so that's a little session using linear
discriminant analysis and there's many
other approaches there's some more
examples in the book
um and you should have a look there